Let's take a look at this sales lead file.
Here on my screen we have a CSV download that we got from our sales team.
As you can see, the data here is pretty broad.
It does seem to have an interesting mix of descriptive data in
addition to some information that looks a little bit more facty.
But how we use this table,
whether as a fact table or a dimension table,
potentially even both will drive some of our next steps.
First, let's proceed with getting the data.
I've already downloaded this data set and saved it to my folder for this class.
So now we can go to Power BI and use the get data function to load it in.
Now in Power BI,
I'm going to select get data,
text or CSV file, connect.
I'll choose my sales leaf file that we just looked at.
Here we have our default load from Power BI.
Power BI has quickly and correctly determined that
the delimiter here for our CSV file is a comma.
But if it had guessed wrong for any reason,
you could choose from this drop-down list to correct it,
to make sure that you have the right delimiter,
which is used to determine what goes into each column based on the CSV file.
From here, you can either select load if this all looks perfect and
you have no updates that you need to make or you can choose transform data,
which will bring this to the Power Query Editor.
I'm going to go ahead and select transform data.
Selecting transform data brought us to the Power Query Editor page.
As you can see, the sales leads file is here on
the left ready for any updates to be made to it.
If I wanted to add another query,
all I would need to do at this stage is select new source.
That same get data list of options would be available and I would repeat the same steps.